Mình sẽ mấy cái bắt tên chụm xem mấy quay lại sau 1 tháng.
Tây không phải mấy quá.
Nên mấy cái trông buông xin ở đâu đi không?
Sau khi mà mình sẽ mấy cái mấy dất đẩy ở đây.
Mình cũng đã có những cái phương át tìm bạn ý.
Nhưng mà, chứ tìm được, tìm cho mình đang có đơn hàng.
Chịa nhìn bạn ý đi vào và mình đã bật đầu là lịch kế hoạch để có mạn đi lạch.
Đúng không có gì đi vào thì bạn ý đẹp tổ thóa không nghĩ mình thành đơn hình và tạm đi ra.
Thôi tay cho trên lại rồi.
Mình sẽ mấy cái xin năm 2018, đúng ta và mấy.
Và bạn ý lên đây ở họ đi học.
Đi ăn sổn để tiêu xa, có ý đi các bạn mạc.
Và ý chỉ chuyên lấy cho xe với k kì khu và bắt tạy thì tính tổn đến hứa trước là in đất là đặt của bốn buông vụ thôi.
Chứ ở đây là bạn ý rất nhiều người mình thường thôi.
Tất là thông thạch, đôi khi là mình có lịch tính là mình xử bất nhận.
Nếu đau chỉ có mình và bạn mình sau đó thì mình đã vi động thêm một vài game đi.
Sai quyết trang của này, không từng tạm với bây giờ.
Các ngón nhỏ có thể thông được nhau và những chiếc xe mọi người thường đi hay đi ở dưới nhà.
Còn phải không quyền thì chẳng á, chỉ có thể là những người ngon cho các bạn.